jean marc bonjour alors tout d'abord
première question quel est le poids que
pour amazon dans le commerce de détail
et ce qui profite du confinement
écoutez la réponse est oui
de toute évidence amazon ce géant
américain de la vente en ligne profite
du déconfinement dans le monde entier
notamment en occident notamment en
france mais pas seulement amazon
d'ailleurs toute la vente en ligne en
profitent alors la colère des petits
commerçants et pasquet en étant fermé en
fermant boutique ils ont perdu leur
clientèle leur chiffre d'affaires et il
trouve ça injuste dans la mesure où bien
sûr ils ont fait des efforts de
protection contre les risques de
contagion du du virage c'est le cas des
magasins de vêtements des fleuristes des
libraires les magasins de jouets par
exemple ils sont fortement pénalisés
parce qu'ils comptent énormément sur le
mois de décembre pour faire leur chiffre
d'affaires c'est assez injuste parce que
la définition des commerces dits
essentiels est quand même assez floue 1
et en plus vous avez des grandes
surfaces qui restent ouvertes elles
vendent à peu près tout alors que les
conditions sanitaires dans les
hypermarchés sont pas forcément très
sécurisé donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un
problème d'équité on va avoir beaucoup
de faillites ya un problème social qui
se pointent peut-être 300000 emplois de
perdus peut-être 100000 commerçante
obligé de fermer la porte et
parallèlement et bien on voit amazon qui
récupère la situation avec des projets
d'extension des projets de l'entrepôt je
rappelle que le marché français
pour amazon c'est devenu son premier
marché il croît de 15 à 20% par an et ce
marché des biens amazon le prend
évidemment sur les petites qui
disparaissent alors cette expansion
inquiète beaucoup de gens des syndicats
des élus et amazon semble avoir
désormais des
oui pour faciliter son expansion c'est
vrai ça inquiète même la commission
européenne vous en parliez mais le tout
ça c'est très politique à vous avez des
élus qui refusent la construction de
tels ou tels entrepôt dans l'eure dans
leur espace mais vous avez des syndicats
qui attaquent l'amazone en justice pour
non respect de certaines dispositions du
droit du travail
vous avez aussi au parlement des députés
qui accuse amazon de ne pas payer
d'impôts en france alors qu'un la zone
travail en france alors je dis tout ça
est très politique c'est une façon de
soutenir évidemment le petit commerce
par une communication assez agressive
il ya quand même un côté bouc émissaire
aussi dans ceux dans ce n'est pas
pourquoi
d'abord parce que le succès de l'amazone
il est fait par le consommateur
on n'oblige pas le consommateur à se
brancher sur amazon il y va parce que
c'est plus pratique parce que c'est
ouvert
parce qu'un référencement très large
ensuite les élus aussi sont très
prudents parce que comme kalamazoo créé
un entrepôt en région ça représente
quand même beaucoup d'emplois le digital
dans son ensemble e-commerce a détruit
sert beaucoup dans quoi on parle de 500
mille emplois détruits au cours des dix
dernières années mais il en a créé
encore davantage alors c'est vrai qu'il
ya un problème fiscal qui est liée aux
gars femme la france est d'ailleurs le
seul pays en europe à percevoir la taxe
il a mal à voir imposer on attend que
l'europe là de ce point de vue passe un
effort et se réveille enfin parce que
c'est quand même fortement déconcertant
de voir des gros gars femmes travailler
en toute impunité fiscale jean marc
green question se pose quel est l'avenir
du petit commerce de proximité
alors c'est évidemment une question qui
se pose elle va d'ailleurs se poser au
gouvernement qui doit prendre un certain
nombre de mesures concernant le le
confinement
aujourd'hui ou demain si on écoute les
petits commerçants faudrait que la
france ferme amazon oui ok quid des
consommateurs je crois qu'il sait même
pas possible d'envisager ça même en rêve
alors à très court terme
le petit commerce doit bénéficier des
aides de l'état bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie a confirmé sur
mass partiel aide directe il ya un
problème sur les loyers à payer aux
bailleurs parce que il faudra régler
tout ça par une négociation à
les bailleurs avec les propriétaire de
deux magasins
ce n'est pas évident à faire alors à
moyen terme il faut que le commerce
accepte la mutation digital vous avez
d'ailleurs beaucoup de commerçants on en
parle moins de ceux là qui ont après la
vente en ligne lors du premier
confinement la vente en ligne viendra en
complément ou vient encore bien
aujourd'hui en compte nullement de la
vente en boutique alors ça passe par
quoi ça passe par la création d'un site
de e-commerce dédié aux commerçants mais
encore là il faut être passible et
puissant ça passe aussi par le click and
collect qui est en train de se
développer à la vitesse grand v
c'est à dire un téléphone au magasin on
envoie un mail et puis on vient prendre
la marchandise où est cette personne
aziz nous est livré ça peut aussi passer
par facebook facebook beaucoup de
commerçants ont des pages commerciales
sur facebook les restaurateurs notamment
qui font de la vente à emporter et puis
je vais être braqués beaucoup mais les
petits commerçants peuvent aussi passer
par les market places existantes
priceminister cdiscount darty même les
grandes surfaces même les grands
hypermarchés ont leur propre site
internet et ils accueillent eux aussi
des commerçants sur ce site internet
alors je vais encore que je vous
surprendre amazon amazon dont on parle
tant et bien accueilli une multitude de
producteurs de négociants et de
commerçants français pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont ouvert un stand sur amazon à
la zone sepa un grand magasin dans
lequel on serait capable de trouver tout
et n'importe quoi un réseau c'est que tu
me nomme galerie marchande dans laquelle
s'installe un certain nombre de
commerçants plus de 60% du commerce
amazon effet aussi par des commerçants
français
alors oui on pourrait regretter qu'il
n'y ait pas un amazon made in france
bien sûr mais on peut aussi tout
imaginer on peut on peut attendre des
commerçants qu'ils passent eux aussi par
ses marques et de place
on peut tout imaginer je vous disais
tout sauf de croire que le consommateur
parce que c'est lui qui dirige tout kid
râle c'est le consommateur on peut on ne
peut pas penser qu'il abandonnera cette
habitude qui est en train de prendre
et qui c'est une habitude qui sera une
habitude une rade forcément forcément
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre pour
toutes ces précisions